[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video i've got some
interesting news that just came out
which affects the fantastic beasts
film franchise it turns out johnny depp
the actor that plays the main antagonist
in the films
grindelwald has been fired by warner
brothers
just today november 6th he left the
following post on his instagram
in light of recent events i would like
to make the following short statement
firstly i'd like to thank everybody who
has gifted me with their support
and loyalty secondly i wish to let you
know that i've been asked to resign
by warner brothers from my role as
grindelwald in fantastic beasts
and i've respected and agreed to that
request finally i wish to say this
the surreal judgment of the court in the
uk will not change my fight to tell the
truth and i confirm that i plan to
appeal
my resolve remains strong and i intend
to prove that the allegations against me
are false my life and career will not be
defined by this moment in time
thank you for reading sincerely johnny
depp
the news comes after the closing of
legal battle between depp and the uk
newspaper over libel claims that depp
was abusive to his wife
grindelwald's character is integral to
the harry potter series
he is the main antagonist the terrorizer
of the wasting world
and without him there's not much of a
film left so now you're probably asking
yourself
will the films continue rest assured the
films will continue
we heard just earlier last month that
filming had begun on fantastic beasts 3
and given that filming has only just
resumed i'm sure they went ahead without
him
i'll also say this his casting was never
exceedingly popular to begin with
as many people just thought hey that's
johnny depp and not
ooh that's grindelwald even though i
learn to like him in the role
i don't think that he is irreplaceable
by any means and i'm interested to see
who will be recast in the role moving
forward
we've also got three more films to go so
we're probably going to become more
accustomed to the new actor
warner bros made the following statement
in response to dropping the actor
johnny depp will leave the fantastic
beasts franchise we thank him for his
work on the film so far
fantastic beasts 3 is currently in
production and the role of gaelic
grindelwald
will be rescheduled the film will hit
theaters in the summer of 2022
it's interesting that we're only just
now seeing the summer 2022
release date as previously the film was
reported to be released
november 2021 in fact the film was
originally supposed to come out this
november but for reasons like
a script to read write and kovid the
film had to be pushed back
this is the first i've heard about the
summer 2022 date
but oh well i'm just happy that the film
is still going forward
and the magic will continue in 2016 we
got fantastic beasts somewhere to find
them
the first installment of the five-part
film series that introduced us to a
wizarding world
during a different time placing an
emphasis on all sorts of new and
never-before-seen characters
creatures and places we saw the
wizarding world in america for the first
time
creatures like nifflers new magic and
even a new antagonist
in 2018 the follow-up to the first film
and the second part of the five
film series was released fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald
the crimes of grindelwald expanded on
this new world further but
in order to make things even more
interesting began to incorporate
elements of the wizarding world
that we already knew and loved in the
form of characters places and dialogue
the film ended on a pretty big
cliffhanger and the films were clearly
not released without the
intention of completing the five part
series and so many questions remained
unanswered when the credits began to
roll
all five films were originally supposed
to be released in the following order
2016 2018 2020
2022 2024 so now we're probably looking
at
2016 2018 2022
2024 2026 and i guess the only good news
about
that is that in a weird way prolonging
the movies keeps the magic alive a bit
i guess the next question is who will be
the next girl at grindelwald
leave a comment down below until next
time it does not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live
you